al trois cent mille personnes dans les
rues de vilnius pour demander la liberté
et l'indépendance en lituanie l'arrivée
de mikhaïl gorbatchev dans les pays
baltes s'est déroulée dans une ambiance
très tendue
trop enfants immigrés pour le conseil
municipal de montfermeil il ne prend
plus en charge les frais de
fonctionnement de 2 des écoles primaires
enfin nouveau rebondissement dans la
sphère grégory lettre du corbeau daté de
juillet 85 et jusqu alors inexploité
pour et s'innocenter définitivement
bernard laroche assassiné en 85 mais
tout de suite l'exploit réalisé par le
skieur franck piccard premier français
vainqueur depuis vingt ans d'une
descente de la coupe du monde c'était à
schladming en autriche cet après midi
tout le monde attendait bien sûr le
grand favori le suisse zurbriggen mais
picard voulait remporter cette victoire
et il s'est battu sans complexe résultat
il s'est retrouvé sur la première marche
du podium
jean-philippe dire prendre picard n'est
pas homme à se satisfaire d'une place
d'honneur
très à l'aise sur le tracé pentues de
schladming en autriche ils attaquent
sans se poser de questions champion
olympique de super g en le skieur des
saisies c'est qu'il possède les moyens
techniques pour briller en descente et
il va le prouver magnifiquement en
signant sur la neige artificielle
superbe victoire d'une minute une
secondes et 31 centièmes de bonheur que
picard qui s'impose devant l'italien
j'ai dit na et le suisse marc autre
bonne surprise la très belle 4e place
décrochée par le jeune denis rey qui
termine en trombe à sept centièmes du
podium
si franck piccard a parfaitement négocié
son parcours l'autrichien michael race
va lui se transformer en sauteur à skis
un vol plané impressionnant qu'il
termine au beau milieu des spectateurs
massés tout au long de la piste
politique qui est la polémique au sein
du rpr alors que jacques chirac a reçu
cet après midi le soutien de la majorité
des parlementaires de son mouvement
charles pasqua et philippe seguin ont
atténué quelque peu le sens de leur
action
on a les deux hommes réunis pour une
conférence de presse dans un grand hôtel
parisien n'ont pas tellement remis en
cause la personnalité de jacques chirac
en revanche s'ils n'ont pas été très
tendre avec les choix politiques du
mouvement et en ce qui concerne le
manque de débat démocratique on écoute
tout de suite dans quelques secondes
charles pasqua
nous nous considérons que le rpr a une
vocation qu'elle a qu'il a un message à
délivrer alors est-ce que le rpr va
rester frileux ce qui va rester un
mouvement gestionnaire est ce qui va se
contenter de continuer à gérer en
quelque sorte son pré carré ou au
contraire retrouvant l'inspiration des
grandes idées gaullistes
est ce qu'il va être capable de se
régénérer dont on retrouve à la fois son
inspiration et par là même son audience
dans les milieux populaires
c'est cela le débat que nous lançons
salle et rien d'autre philippe seguin
est en direct d'epinal monsieur seguin
pardonnez-moi de formuler ainsi ma
question pourriez vous nous expliquer ce
que vous avez voulu faire exactement
avec charles pasqua
ça je veux dire que c'est une très bonne
question parce que en entendant en
entendant les comme auxerre de votre
journal je me dis qu'il ya effectivement
un effort d'explication à faire
j'entends dire que nous avons atténué le
sens de notre démarche mais diable en
quoi alors il semblerait qu'on soit tous
surpris aujourd'hui parce que nous
n'avons pas attaqué la personne de
jacques chirac
mais pourquoi est-on surpris quand avons
nous dit que nous attaquions jacques
chirac il y a eu une intoxication qui
s'est développée mais qu'on se rapporte
à notre bref communiqué didia 48 heures
nous n'avons pas une seule fois mis en
cause jacques chirac et tout le reste
est à l'avenant on dit jacques chirac a
gagné son bras de fer contre ce pasqua
et ses gains il pourrait gagner un bras
de fer s'il y avait effectivement eu un
bras de fer ont dit par ailleurs que
nous allons faire amende honorable une
amende honorable de quoi nous nous
exprimons aujourd'hui pour la première
fois dans le détail pour expliquer notre
démarche
il faut pas se laisser intoxiquer par
ceux qui depuis 48 heures on cherchait
sans nous avoir entendus à donner un
autre sens à notre démarche parce que
c'était leur intérêt comment expliquez
vous alors que les députés rpr est aussi
vivement réagi depuis deux jours à ce
que eux appellent une attaque contre
jacques chirac mais ils n'ont pas
vivement réagi à ce qu'il considère
comme une attaque à jacques chirac ils
ont simplement exprimer leur fidélité à
jacques chirac
je vais vous le dire si j'avais été à
paris à l'heure de cette réunion j
aurais étè et j'aurais moi-même
renouveler ma fidélité à jacques chirac
j'ai d'ailleurs si j'ose dire une preuve
je publie ces jours ci un livre de 180
pages où je confirme où je confirme mon
attachement à jacques chirac
mais je suis si attaché à jacques chirac
douillet vous que je souhaite pouvoir
sortir le mouvement dont il est le
président de l'ornière dans laquelle il
se trouve
faute de quoi contrairement mon espoir
mon neveu jacques chirac ne sera pas
président de la république ce qui serait
détestable
alors ce que vous reproche alain juppé
qui a lui donc bien parler d'agression à
votre avis c'est d'avoir commis un crime
de lèse majesté
c'est ce que j'ai cru le comprendre mais
revenons aux faits là encore qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que nous avons fait notre
mouvement fait un effort de
démocratisation jeu la plaine mais veut
tant mieux bon on nous dit il faut
déposer les contributions bien nous les
déposants ont dit on va essayer de faire
une synthèse de toutes ces contributions
parce que maintenant chez nous c'est
démocratique
on essaye de faire cette synthèse et
puis ce trou ça n'a rien de dramatique
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire cette
synthèse et nous allons donc déposé une
contribution face à la contribution du
secrétaire-général mais c'est ça la
démocratie
alors on nous oppose une sorte de 49,3
la brutale contrairement à l'esprit de
la réforme qui était supposée avoir été
faite au rpr et on nous dit si vous ne
prenez pas le texte de monsieur juppé a
par définition ça veut dire que vous
êtes contre chirac mais nous refusons
d'être enfermé dans cette contradiction
il nous voulons que ce débat ait lieu si
c'est bien cette récente que vous voulez
la faire avec charles pasqua vous
n'étiez pas très proche de charles
pasqua jusqu alors comment expliquez
vous sa chance du mois le port de
mémoire alors j'entends dire sur charles
pasqua des choses qui me qui me plonge
dans la stupéfaction la plus grande il y
a des gens qui vous donne l'impression
d'un charles pasqua pestiférés mais
enfin un certain nombre de ceux qui ont
lancé contre lui la nappe
elles appartiennent quand même au même
mouvement politique que lui ça veut dire
j'imagine qu'ils ont quelque chose en
commun avec lui et d'autres par leur
présence au gouvernement à ses côtés n'a
pas paru leur poser des problèmes de
promiscuité
en vérité le mouvement gaulliste a
toujours été un mouvement divers
composés d'hommes et de femmes de
sensibilités différentes c'est sa
caractéristique c'est sa raison d'être
alors il se trouve que sur l'essentiel
et au delà de nos différences avec
charles pasqua un moment important de
l'histoire de notre mouvement qui ne se
porte pas bien
il n'est que de vous entendre
régulièrement pour se l'entendre dire un
moment crucial de l'histoire de notre
mouvement nous disons à l'occasion
d'assises
il ne faut pas faire des assises de
routine il faut nous régénérer
voilà monsieur seguin vous reste en
direct avec nous à epinal conférence de
presse cet après-midi de valéry giscard
d'estaing mais le numéro de l'udf a
profité de cette tempête au sein du rpr
pour prôner l'union au sein de
l'opposition et la morale en politique
on écoute tout de suite je crois qu'il
ya à l'heure actuelle grandes attentes
de l'opinion publique et que les
dirigeants politiques et les appareils
politiques devraient écouter cet appel
de l'opinion publique au fond qu'est-ce
que les français disent aux hommes
politiques
il leur dit vous vous occuper de vos
problèmes et pourquoi vous nous occuper
pas des nôtres
je crois qu'à l'heure actuelle nous
devons présenter des solutions simples à
l'opinion publique elle voit bien que
dans ce monde troublé
on ne peut pas avoir des structures trop
compliqué ou des systèmes de
représentation trop artificiel nous
avons besoin d'une grande formation
commune de l'opposition et je souhaite
que les mouvements cours ici ou là soit
au fond des moyens des signes par
lesquelles on voit naître cette grande
formation commune de l'opposition
philippe seguin vous y croyait cette
grande formation commune de l'opposition
bien sûr et nous y travaillons nous
voulons la rénovation par le gaullisme
la rénovation du gaullisme c'est notre
ambition
merci monsieur seguin d'avoir accepté de
répondre à notre invitation alors michel
lemaire nous venons de faire le point
sur la crise au sein du rpr le parti
communiste
de son côté est un peu en état de
déliquescence le parti socialiste est
presque menacé d'implosion j'allais dire
comment expliquez-vous toute cette
effervescence dans la classe politique
bon il faut tout de même faire la part
des choses il ya une partie des aspects
qui sont conjoncturelles la proximité
des congrès et l'absence déchets
d'échéances électorales immédiate
favorise naturellement le débat mais il
ya aussi des raisons plus profondes et
des raisons institutionnelles dont la
prépondérance de l'élection
présidentielle qui est de plus en plus
critiqué aujourd'hui va naturellement
entraîner des rivalités de personnes
mais en plus il est bien évident qu'une
élection ne se gagne pas avec un noyau
dur est tous partis dominants est
forcément un parti attrape tout avec
toutes les difficultés ensuite que ça
représente pour organiser ces courants
ces tendances et tous les germes de
sites de dissensions que ça présente à
ce qui apparaît aussi un petit peu des
conflits de générations dans cette
partie oui bien sûr mais c'est pas là
l'essentiel
mais à tous les niveaux songez par
exemple qu'en ce qui concerne les mères
un mur sur quatre aujourd'hui est un
retraité
bon c'est bien pour les petites communes
mais ça favorise pas tellement
l'émergence d'une nouvelle couche d'élus
une ou deux raisons pourrait en donner
beaucoup d'autres supplémentaires la
mise au rebut des grands mythes
simplificateur quand on réagissait en
termes droite gauche est un peu étroit
c'était un profond sentiment même si
aujourd'hui des réponses elles sont plus
difficiles
et puis bon bah l'aspiration de qui est
dû à l'ère des temps un air vif
aujourd'hui partout on demande plus de
démocratie plus de participation et les
partis politiques français n'ont pas
vraiment encore sur ce point réalisé
leur mue et tant qu'ils ne font pas cela
posera des problèmes l'air vif de la
démocratie souffle aussi bien sûr à
l'étranger trois cent mille personnes
ont accueilli michael gorbatchev
aujourd'hui en lituanie la petite
république balte annexées par l'union
soviétique en 1940 démontre par le
nombre sa volonté d'indépendance et dans
le même temps mihai gambettes soir à
respecter son programme à la lettre
rencontre avec les membres du parti
communiste local et bains de foule
officielle est que le numéro un
soviétique ne pourra pas ignorer pendant
tout son voyage cette contestation
grandissante
sofidy ue
trois cent mille personnes vilnius cet
après midi trois cent mille personnes
allumant des bougies et brandissant des
drapeaux lituaniens trois cent mille
personnes venues dans des cars spéciaux
de tous les coins des la lituanie pour
revendiquer l'indépendance de leur
république
à l'origine de cette manifestation la
visite michail gorbatchev
la première un numéro un soviétique dans
cette république une visite dite de
travail façon discrète d'évoquer le
problème des nationalités en urss un
problème posé par le pc lituanie a lui
même qui en décembre dernier proclamait
son indépendance vis-à-vis de moscou
gorbatchev a répondu aujourd'hui par un
symbole en déposant une gerbe au
monument de lénine
histoire de rappeler que le petit père
des peuples est aussi celui des
lituaniens le numéro un soviétique
ensuite pris son traditionnel bain de
foule 45 minutes d'un dialogue parfois
vifs avec la population des personnes
doutent que la lituanie fasse partie de
l'union soviétique ce n'est pas sérieux
a déclaré gorbatchev mais le premier
secrétaire sait qu'il lui faut vite
trouver une solution entre des
nationalismes fort et le risque d'un
éclatement de l'urss
la marge de manoeuvre est étroite
gorbatchev souhaite une refonte des
relations au sein de l'union soviétique
le tout est de savoir comment doute que
toutes les républiques du rss mais les
yeux fixés les jours prochains sur la
lituanie
c'est peut-être ici que gorbatchev
révélera la nouvelle règle du jeu de
l'actualité internationale en bref voici
maintenant les télégrammes de l'étranger
préparer commenter ce soir par jean paul
girouard
l'état d'urgence at il été décrété en
albanie selon un journal yougoslave
oui cette mesure aurait été prise en
réponse à des soulèvements populaires
contre le régime communiste dans la
deuxième ville du pays
calomnie a répondu la diplomatie
albanaise qui démentent aussi toute
persécution contre la minorité grecque
du pays travel a envoyé aux agences de
presse ce reportage pour appuyer son
propos
à en croire ces images de valeo 6 riante
que leurs habitants il ne se passe
toujours rien en albanie
roland dumas en roumanie le ministre des
affaires étrangères a proposé aux
dirigeants roumains l'aide de la france
pour la reconstruction du pays
à eux de déterminer leurs priorités
selon les premiers entretiens ils sont
essentiellement alimentaires et
énergétiques
les curieux ont timidement arpenter la
place tiananmen ce matin après la levée
de la loi martiale décrétée hier pour
nombre d'observateurs les dissidents un
exil les semble-t-il une large part de
la population
il ne s'agit que d'un geste de façade à
destination de l'étranger
la chasse aux meneurs continue chilingo
l'une des dirigeantes du printemps de
pékin aurait été arrêtée alors qu'elle
cherchait à fuir le pays
la plomberie nouvelle discipline
spatiale l'équipage de columbia a dû
colmater répond j'ai une fuite d'un
litre d'eau 1 litre ça paraît peu mais
lorsqu'on est en apesanteur ex que c'est
tout se transforme en centaines de
toutes lettres flottante
c'est vraiment du sport en france
nouvelle polémique à montfermeil en
seine-saint-denis le conseil municipal a
décidé de ne plus prendre en charge les
frais de fonctionnement sauf le
chauffage de deux écoles primaires et
maternelles qui ont accepté des enfants
d'immigrés non souhaitée par le maire et
le préfet a mise en demeure ne m'en le
maire de montfermeil de revenir sur sa
décision et de son côté lionel jospin a
annoncé la prise en charge par l'état
des frais de fonctionnement tout en
jugeant inacceptable l'attitude de
pierre bernard reportage michel valet
95% des enfants début maternelle de la
cité des bosquets sont d'origine
étrangère
c'est le constat est le cauchemar du
maire de montfermeil qui vient de faire
monter la pression avec la délibération
de son conseil municipal
il a voté la suspension des services de
cantine de nettoyage et d'assistance
bonnes âmes la mairie laissera le
chauffage on en est là à montfermeil
sus à l'immigration si vous avez une
autre solution est ce que nous prenons
nous ne faisons pas gaieté de coeur
trouver de la donner là on apprendre
ainsi les bonnes l'îlot de notoriété
c'est la fameuse cité des bosquets où un
tiers des vingt-quatre mille habitants
de montfermeil résident
la majorité des immigrés monsieur
bernard souhaite qu'ils soient répartis
sur le territoire national et veut les
inciter à partir c'est le sens de la
délibération de ce conseil municipal une
décision vilipendé par l'opposition qui
parle d' exclusion et demande que le
maire soit sanctionné reste que les
enfants font figure de bouc émissaire
dans cette affaire la préfecture se
propose d'articuler une solution de
substitution
tout en mettant le maire en demeure de
revenir sur sa décision
déjà sanctionné dans l'esprit par le
tribunal administratif en octobre
dernier
c'est ce pouvoir de substitution que la
loi me donne et qui me permet de le
faire je le fais les dépenses qui vont
être engagées à cette occasion seront
bien entendu mise à la charge de la
commune une nouvelle lettre anonyme
pourrait relancer l' affaire grégory le
feuilleton judiciaire rebondit à nouveau
dans les vosges un courrier adressé au
grand père villemin étaient archivés
depuis 1985
cette lettre n'avait jamais été exploité
jusqu alors et ce soir elle pourrait
bien tout simplement innocenter les
principaux protagonistes de la fe y
compris bernard laroche assassiné en 85
de nancy didier guillot cellule une
lettre de menaces reçue en juillet 85
par la grand-mère de grégory lettre dont
l'écriture ressemble fortement à celle
de la lettre de revendication de
l'assassinât de l'enfant resté lettre
morte dans le dossier pendant quatre ans
ce document a attiré l'attention du
magistrat car par sadate juillet 85 et
son contenu elle disculperaient à la
fois christine villemin et bernard
laroche
encore faut-il qu'il s'agisse bien d'une
lettre du corbeau de la vologne c'est ce
que les expertises commandées devront
déterminer si c'est le cas le président
simon disposera d'un élément
supplémentaire pour étayer sa thèse qui
viendra compléter les éléments
concernant le mobile du crime car ces
deux jours d'auditions pour en effet
permis de confirmer l'hypothèse de la
vengeance visant albert lynds vermand il
apparaît d'une manière certaine que le
mobile est un mobile unique et a
toujours visé
halle berry
quand on s'est aperçu qu'on ne pouvait
pas entraîner la mort volontaire
d'albertville 1 on a touché
le point le plus sensible c'est à dire
son petit fils il y avait également un
tiercé quarté + aujourd'hui à cagnes sur
mer 4 15,5 dans l'ordre 688 francs 50
dans le désordre pas terrible son
dauphin et puis le quartier +4 15,5 on
s'est beaucoup mieux avec 1821 francs 60
et dans un ordre différent seulement 72
français très peu normal un temps la
météo complète de florence klein le
programme de la soirée sur l'a31 à 20h30
au talent international d'un film
britannique avec elizabeth taylor et
richard burton à 22h35 soir 3 présenté
par philippe de sagna 23h océanique
demain le 19/20 vous sera présentée par
gérard pinson dans un instant rester
fidèle à florence cassez météo
l'anticyclone recouvre l'ensemble du
pays tout va très bien
à bientôt bonsoir bonsoir donne